tu deviens à
39 ans le nouveau géant de la peinture américaine
et les gens te comparent à 20 wow
[Applaudissements]
je suppose que quand tu es peintre
ils te comparent à d'autres peintres
je suppose que c'est une façon pour les gens de
comprendre les choses que tu sais
ils euh t'attachent autre chose donc
c'est une poignée qu'ils
pourraient qu'ils peuvent euh digérer oui
donc tu es né à brooklyn et quand tu
étais jeune ta famille est allée au texas
et là à cause de la solitude peut-être que
tu as commencé à peindre tu sais
je  je peignais toujours ouais ouais j'étais
seul quand j'étais petit avant d'être
détective ouais non euh
mais je suppose que déménager au texas a eu un grand
effet sur mon
travail d'une manière juste une sorte de
déplacement d'être dans un endroit étrange
est-ce dans  texas qu'il y avait un gars qui
vivait près de chez vous
et il peignait des chevaux et vous étiez
très impressionné par lui
euh non c'est drôle tu as une petite histoire
hein
ouais maintenant quand j'étais petit euh trois ans
il y avait quelqu'un qui dessinait un cheval en
floride ouais
donc je tri  ed de le faire aussi et je l'ai fait et
ma mère a pensé que c'était très bien,
donc c'était une sorte de début pavlovien,
vous savez,
votre première exposition était à Houston
et elle n'a pas été très bien accueillie par les
critiques
euh c'est beaucoup à attendre  pour que les gens
comprennent vos peintures
peut-être ouais alors vous avez décidé de travailler comme
cuisinier maintenant
et de payer votre voyage en europe je
cuisinais dans différents restaurants comme
travail
ouais et
[Musique]
je suppose que la première fois que je suis venu à paris
c'était en 76
il n'y a pas si longtemps, mais
expliquez-nous ce qui vous est arrivé à
barcelone quand vous étiez dans son hôtel
et que vous avez découvert votre métier euh l'
histoire de barcelone est une histoire
comme n'importe quelle autre histoire ouais je veux dire c'est une
chose légendaire
peut-être pas mais en gros euh je  comme
le travail de
gaudi beaucoup le parc guell
était très beau et tu as vu le
matin la sagrana familia
ouais j'ai vu tout son tout son euh son
travail à barcelone mais
j'ai aussi vu une mosaïque euh très minable sur un
mur dans un  très mauvais restaurant
et  je pensais que les assiettes blanches c'était
son hôtel l'après midi quand tu rentrais
tu allais à l'endroit où était ton
armoire et
tu décidais de casser des assiettes et de les
coller
sur du bois ouais euh il y avait un placard qui
était un très beau euh
taille ouais est sorti du mur c'était à
taille humaine
donc je pensais juste que
c'était la première euh qui était la première
armature pour la première peinture sur plaque
et puis en quatre ans tu es devenu l'
un des peintres les plus chers au
monde très
pas non  facilement mais très rapidement vous savez
je veux dire je pense qu'il y a beaucoup de
peintures qui sont chères
mais cela ne les rend pas nécessairement bonnes
mais je mais les gens semblent dire que par
ici je suppose qu'ils pensent que les américains
ont beaucoup d'argent
ouais je  je sais pas tu as
dit que tu t'inspires de n'importe quoi du moment que ça
excite ta curiosité ouais
ouais donc tu digères tout et
tu le remets tout seul
ouais donc je dirais que gaudi n'était pas
plus important que de venir h  Ici aujourd'hui,
vous savez ou
quelque chose qui aurait pu
arriver au coin de la rue
et très souvent vous mélangez différents styles
dans vos peintures pour dire aussi l'
abstraction et la figuration et cela
annule la
discussion à ce sujet maintenant
ouais je ne fais pas vraiment un
la différenciation entre la peinture
qui contient des personnages ou la peinture qui
ne fait pas
ouais ce qui rend une peinture moderne, c'est si
elle a une sorte d'
utilité envers le spectateur ou
envers l'artiste je veux dire que je les fais
pour moi
quand les gens regardent  eux,
soit ils en retirent quelque chose, soit
ils ne le font pas, mais euh
mais je pense que je ne pense pas nécessairement
que les peintures qui ont juste des
personnages
sont modernes ou que les peintures qui ont juste des
rectangles peints dessus sont modernes
donc
et ii  j'ai fait des peintures qui avaient deux
panneaux où je juxtaposais
une image abstraite sur une image figurative
mais
ce n'était que quelques peintures quels sont
les peintres qui vous inspirent le plus
picasso euh j'aime la photo  asso beaucoup
ouais j'aime beaucoup trop les peintures
tardives pour
te dire que toi tu aimes beaucoup
les dessins d'asso ouais je pense qu'ils sont géniaux
ouais
je pense qu'ils sont euh tu es sûr que tu t'es
inspiré des martiaux il y a un  super
pièce que joseph boys a
faite c'est encadré et il y a du
chocolat dessus et les mots sont
écrits
le silence de marcel duchamp est
surfait
que pensez vous des peintres
français des vrais peintres français
comme la figuration combats
[Musique]
euh ça m'intéresse pas trop  cette
peinture ouais je pense euh
la peintre française la plus intéressante que je
connaisse est une femme qui s'appelle anne duong
et ses peintures
ont le même sentiment que nos
dessins d'orteils tu sais tu viens très souvent à
paris non
je l'aime beaucoup ici tu as beaucoup de
des amis ici à paris ouais c'est très
agréable d'avoir des amis parce que
je me souviens quand j'étais ici quand
je ne connaissais personne et
j'avais du mal à acheter un steak freak
au latin clooney
et donc c'est sympa quand tu y vas et  les gens
te laissent  ous dans un restaurant ou dans un bar
ou
comment avez vous
decouvert le magasin 30 chez les barbiers
je revenais de l'aeroport un jour
et j'etais pres d'un monmouth
et je cherchais dans tout cela ce
que vous avez appele une impression le magasin
la verrière devant eux était rose
et blanche
et euh ils ressemblaient à des peintures pour moi
et donc euh a décidé de peindre dessus ouais
je suis allé dans le magasin et j'ai demandé si je
pouvais les
acheter et ils ont pensé que j'étais fou alors j'ai
demandé à un français  un ami et ils
ne les lui ont pas
bien donnés d'abord j'ai demandé à un gars nommé
il travaillait avec caroline loeb et
euh
ils ne les lui ont pas donnés alors j'ai appelé
andré démissionner et euh
elle connaissait les gens ou ils savaient qui  elle
était donc
elle a obtenu ce matériel pour moi et j'ai fait
11 peintures
je les ai appelées les peintures tati ouais
et euh
la ligne est la liberté et vos peintures
sont très chères
mais elles sont les plus mais c'est
le prix le moins cher que vous obtiendrez  eux car
nous pouvons les voir à l'ours evolon jusqu'à
e  e mi-mai
et combien en coûte-t-il
bien je ne sais pas vraiment ii je ne sais pas
s'il en reste
à vendre mais il y avait un grand tableau
qui, je suppose, coûterait environ
trois cent mille dollars et les
plus petits que je mets
Je ne sais pas, euh, les moyennes coûtaient 175 000 dollars et la petite était quelle petite mesure encore six pieds de haut, mais c'était comme 120 000, donc elles ne sont pas très chères, ne
voulez-vous pas les exposer à 30 ans
juste  pour une nuit euh
je pense que l'espace dans evans est plus clair
ouais
peut-être qu'il y a trop de vêtements en
turquie ouais mais euh
mais quand je conduis et que je vois tous
les tatistos j'ai l'impression que c'est une
publicité pour l'émission
qui seriez-vous  tu aimes être si
tu ne
jonglais pas avec schneiderlin quel peintre quelle
carte
euh quel peintre je n'aimerais
pas être quelqu'un d'autre ouais
euh
ça ne me dérangerait pas d'être gerard de pardue
pendant quelques heures
euh je pense qu'il est vraiment super  euh
particulièrement dans euh
novaciento tu connais ça euh bertolucci
film je pensais qu'il était vraiment génial
mais je pense qu'il est une
ressource naturelle française ouais je pense qu'il est génial
et si tu devais donner une définition de
toi que dirais-tu
juste pour voir la ligne juste une phrase sur
ta tombe
dans le dictionnaire si tu  veux vers
la fin
j'étais je commençais juste
[Musique]
bleu